- Okay, welcome, everyone.
And shut up.
Love the excitement.
Can't take the noise.
Now, you're here because
you're Chase's biggest fans.
And because your parents
are rich.
- Is ChaseDreams really
on the plane?
- Yes.
- [crying]
- And for your superfans,
it's not just Chase
on the plane,
but the whole Dream family.
[all scream]
- I love you, Cary!
- I love you too.
- Okay, and remember,
once the music starts...
- Hey, Cary, your hair is
looking a lot less swooped.
- I know.
Why didn't you tell me?
I looked crazy.
- Well, I was trying to be
supportive.
Also it was really funny.
- You're the one that told me
to ride the wave.
- I told you to use Chase.
Not become him.
- Now, once we reach
30,000 feet,
we will be streaming live
on ChaseDreams.com.
There are cameras
all over the plane,
except the bathrooms.
Viewers will be able to watch
any camera at any time.
So if you need to yawn, burp,
sneeze, fart,
do it now
and do it fast.
[tiny fart]
Excellent.
- Oh, um, here's a random
question.
Lance.
Just such an idiot.
Right?
- Um, sure?
- But he's, you know,
he's kind of cool, as well.
- Oh, so you're getting back
together with him.
- No!
- Yes.
- No. No.
Never.
I just...I think you should be
nicer to him.
- Okay, Brooke.
God I wish I had seen
those pilots.
- Hey, Car.
I know you're scared of flying,
so I thought you might want to
hold Helen for a little bit.
- You brought a pig on
the plane?
- It's a therapy pig.
I got it for you.
Look, she's very calming.
Unless you hold her the wrong
way, and then she'll attack you
in ways that you never thought
were possible.
- Um, no thank you.
- Okay.
I was just trying to help.
- Okay, folks, we are
ten minutes out
from hearing Chase's new album.
[all scream]
12 incredible songs.
We are talking over 19 minutes
of music.
- 12? I thought he only had
three songs.
- Uh-huh.
And nine remixes.
- Hey, not to be a bummer,
but, um...
How are you doing with today?
- Oh, um,
I'm okay.
- Sorry to bring it up.
- No. No, no.
It's...
It's good. I mean, it's been
almost a year
and no one ever talks
about Dad.
- Yeah, it sucks.
- I wonder if Chase's remembers
it's his birthday.
- I'm sure Mom does.
I hope she's doing okay.
- Hi, guys!
- Oh, God.
- Hey, how, uh, how you doing
with today?
- I'm great. I'm great.
This is such a big day
for Chasey.
And me.
I'm wearing the first sample
from my jewelry line.
- Oh, you have a jewelry line
now.
- Yeah, yeah.
The book was such a hit
that they're letting me move
into apparel now.
This is just a prototype.
The real version will be four
times bigger and heavier.
- Okay, I'm gonna go
check on Chase.
- I'm wearing it on the
livestream to get feedback
from the marketplace.
- Yeah, wow, you...
You're doing a lot.
[rattling]
- Hey, kiddo.
Just wanted to see
how you're doing.
Today.
- I guess I feel a little
weird.
- Yeah, I figured.
Do you want to talk about it?
- Sure.
They put a bunch of filler
in my lips
to make them look kissable,
and now I can't feel them.
- Oh.